reason why
math has an order of operations or is it
just because we decided on that
okay so let me start off by explaining
what order of operations is about uh
if you uh write something like
2 plus 3 times 4
what does it mean right 2 a plus sign
3 a times sine four what does that mean
well it could mean add
two and three together then multiply the
result by four
or it could mean multip work out three
times four first
and then do two plus that at the
beginning
what does it mean well if you look at
for example from language our
computational language
what does two plus three times four turn
into
it turns into the the three times four
turns into the function times with two
arguments
three and four and then the two plus
turns into plus
of two comma times 3
plus 3 comma 4. so that is this is this
thing that is a
collection of the function is it defines
that there are a sequence of functions
that are being used
to those computations and at that point
it is a feature of the underlying
computational language
that the arguments of a function
are evaluated before the function itself
is evaluated so in that setup
if we got that thing that says plus of
two comma
times of three four where uh we've
defined what order we should do these
operations in
but when we just write down two plus
three times four
there's this question of how do we parse
that
how do we decide what that means let me
give an analogy actually that occurs to
me in natural language
uh in natural language we we we have to
decide
is the times a higher precedence
operator
is it something that's going to grab its
arguments first
with higher precedence than the plus
that is going to sort of come in later
and or how is it going to work well
the same kinds of issues in english so
we might say
um let's see uh see if i can make up a
sentence that will have this
uh issue um
let's think we need to figure out a
sentence where there will be
a word that can
um go with
two different possible things depending
on how it's on how things are grouped
um well i mean there's a there's a sort
of a famous
um one that is a little bit about
grouping
you know uh i think it was the title of
a book about punctuation a panda
comes into some place and
eats shoots and leaves
which if you punctuate it in one way it
says
a panda eats shoots like bamboo shoots
and leaves it could also mean the panda
is in the wild west or something
and uh you know goes into a saloon and
eats
and then comma shoots and leaves
so that's an example in english where it
matters kind of how the grouping works
and you can indicate that grouping by a
comma
perhaps in that case but there are other
cases where the way the grouping works
depends on sort of the conventions about
what things mean
so in the case of math this question of
grouping
the the person who asked the question
here
asked sort of is it arbitrary what the
order of operations is the answer is yes
it's arbitrary when those notations were
made up
in the 1400s or so they just sort of
evolved as being
that was how the that the times would be
done before the plus was done
and so on um actually when you get into
other kinds of operations
uh when you do things like um
well actually it's not so obvious in
some in some parts of math it's not so
obvious how the grouping works
so for example if i say 1 minus 2 minus
3
what does that mean it could mean 1
minus
2 minus 3 where the 2 minus 3 is in
parentheses
or it could mean 1 minus 2 minus 3.
so that's what's called associativity
which way round
things group when you just have a single
operator
just to explain a little bit about about
sort of the background to this
when the the what you're basically
trying to do is to turn
a sequence of characters into
something that can be interpreted as
this kind of
set of functions to apply in a sense
you've got to turn that sequence of
characters
into this kind of tree that says do this
then this then this
it's kind of like when people learn to
do sentence diagramming in english
and you say this is the sentence now
let's identify
the noun phrase the verb phrase the noun
phrase that correspond to subject verb
object let's say
that kind of diagramming that sort of
hierarchical diagramming
you do exactly the same thing in
computer languages
and they tend to operate in a way where
the so-called context-free languages
where basically the structure of that
tree that you produce
has the property that every time you
have any time you have
a uh a
a sort of piece of the linguistics that
looks like
this it will be able to have the same
sub-pieces wherever it occurs
in other words the question of whether
that
noun could really be broken into an
adjective and a noun or something like
that
that is allowed to happen whenever you
have a noun phrase
the noun phrase could be a single noun
or it could be an adjective followed by
a noun
both are allowed and it's context free
it doesn't matter
where that noun phrase occurs that that
kind of breaking into
uh the the adjective and the noun can
occur that that happens wherever the
noun phrase occurs
and it's the same thing in computer
languages that they tend to be defined
by this kind of
uh sort of thing that says and now you
have
this intermediate object that's a little
bit like a noun phrase
and it can be decomposed into this and
that decomposition works wherever you
put it
so the the problem of parsing is the
problem of how do you turn a string of
characters
like two plus three times four into
this hierarchical thing that will
eventually be plus of two comma
times of three comma four how do you
how do you arrange that uh that
transformation to happen
okay so the thing you have to decide in
two plus three times four
is which operator binds more tightly
which operator
has higher precedence which operator
should be
uh used first and the convention is that
times is used before plus
now if you have a single operator like
something like
one minus two minus three then you have
the question of what's called
associativity
how should the pieces of that
uh that minus sign being being used how
should they associate should it be 1
minus 2
minus 3 or should it be 1 minus 2 minus
3.
okay so in the case of subtraction it's
usually taken to be
one minus sorry it's usually taken to be
yeah one minus two minus three let's do
division
let's say you've got two slash three
slash four
what does that mean does that left
associate in the sense that it's
what did i say two slash three and then
that whole thing slash four
or is it two slash three slash four
and the results are different they're
mathematically different things
so it matters whether it's left
associative or right associative
in the case of division it's usually
assumed to be less left associative
okay let's do one more example let's do
power let's say you say 2 to the power 3
to the power 4. let's say you write that
as two wedge three wedge four
what does that mean that's actually not
very well defined
in in standard math nobody really
usually talks about what that means
in standard math so if you make a
computer language you have to make the
decision what are you going to have that
mean
if it was 2 to the power 3
all to the power 4 left associative
like slash and minus that wouldn't be so
useful because
2 to the power 3 all to the power 4
is the same as 2 to the power 3 times 4
just as a mathematical fact about powers
so it's more useful to say that power
right associates
so that 2 wedge 3 wedge four is actually
the equivalent of two wedge parenthesis
three wedge four
and i should explain uh perhaps it's
obvious that um
parentheses are the way you sort of
specify how things are going to be
grouped
um you often write things without
parentheses but if you want to say
instead of the 2 plus 3 times 4 if you
wanted to say i want the 2 plus 3 done
first
you put the print put 2 plus 3 in
parenthesis and then say times 4.
so that was um uh
the the the anyway the the concept here
is
this there's this notion of of
precedence of operators
like plus is below times and precedence
and power is above times
so that means that that a power gets
done first
mines more tightly and so on so you
might ask how are the precedences of all
these different operators that you see
in math books
how are they determined it's actually a
very strange thing i i looked at this in
the 1990s because we were introducing
all kinds of exotic operators into
wolfram language and i wanted to know
were people even consistent
in the way that you know a circle plus
what the precedence of that was
relative to a co-product symbol relative
to
all kinds of different things were they
consistent the answer is
there is a surprising degree of
consistency in the mathematical
literature
there's actually a correlation with
something else which is when people
typeset
operators they usually use just a little
bit more space
if the things have lower precedence if
they bind less tightly
it's a sort of more airy presentation as
if to say
oh this thing isn't going to be as
grabby with its arguments
it's a looser kind of thing so so in the
end this
this question of of uh what is the
precedence of operators what is the
which is the fancy version of the what
people learn as order of operations in
elementary math
that's something that is really was
determined historically
and some things are more useful than
others like the example i gave you of
power
it's more useful to say it's right
associative and then it's left
associative
in the case of of subtraction it's more
useful to say it's left associative
because it's super confusing
if it's right associative then 1 minus 2
minus 3
computes the 2 minus 3 first and then
says 1 minus
the minus one and then that's actually
one plus one and
it's very confusing and it's not what
you typically want so
one tries to pick precedences and
associativities
to be kind of what people expect and
people have been surprisingly consistent
in what they want in in
in those regards now the question of
which mathematical operations get
actual symbols individual symbols for
example that's another interesting
question
and in the history of mathematics
for a long time there wasn't
mathematical notation people would just
describe
things using words mathematical notation
was invented
1400s to 1600s mostly and
it was very important for the
communication of mathematics people
before that time people had a hard time
really discussing algebra and quadratic
equations and solving them and all those
kinds of things
quadratic equations have been studied in
antiquity but
the sort of streamlined treatment of
them using algebra really had to
wait for people to invent these
notations like plus signs and
equal signs and things like that it's
worth realizing that
that invention of that notation was in
some ways quite arbitrary
i mean for example the equal sign this
is equal to that
great it's a it's a nice sign we all
know it now there's also the greater
than sign
which means you know a is greater than b
there's a sort of a you know it's a it's
a um
uh it's got a v turned outside but the
big end
towards the a and the little l towards
the b that means a is bigger than b
so that you could people had various
notations for equality
that were so sort of the the notion of
equality now
is it's kind of like instead of having a
greater than sign with a
with a big end and a small end the equal
sign is like
equal equal kind of size on both sides
it's like a like a
you know there's an equal separation
between the lines on both sides and
that's kind of
how it's indicating that this is equal
to that and um
the thing that uh people had different
notations like this chap called
gottfried leibniz who's the guy who
invented the integral sign for example
he had a notation for equality and
inequality that was based on having a
scale you know
weight the scale for measuring weight
where the scale would be down on one
side and up on the other so it would be
like
this is bigger than that so the scale is
lower on that side than on the other
side
and if it's equal the scales are are
sort of uh
uh level so he had notations where we
had things going down on one side up on
the other
rather than at the notation that kind of
survived which was the bigger on one
side smaller on the other
and you know it's worth realizing
there's a lot of tricky stuff with
notation like if i write
a equals b equals c you might think
that what does that mean does that mean
that a b and c
are all equal to each other or does that
mean a is equal to b
and b is equal to c well okay because of
the properties of equality
that means all three of those things are
equal but when it gets a little bit more
elaborate
and what we mean by equality it's not so
obvious that all three things should be
the same
and it could be the case that they were
just the same in pairs and so on
and again those are a bunch of
conventions that one has to pick
explicitly one one's making a
computational language
when one writes math one one usually
just sort of hopes for the best
and assumes that that if there is some
ambiguity people will understand it from
the words around it
but um you know there are different
notations that were invented like i
mentioned got free leibniz invented the
integral sign
he also invented the the d by dx
kind of notation for derivatives and
it's it's pretty famous
uh thing you know when when people learn
calculus and they learn dy divided by dx
then the immediate thing that people say
is well i know
standard algebra why can't i just cancel
the d's
well you can't because they represent
infinitesimals and there's a whole
story about how calculus works but
leibniz when he invented that notation
was very concerned
that people would just cancel the d's
which has been a a
long-term problem in learning calculus
ever since
leibniz was also very down on the
chapter william outread who invented the
times sign
because he said people it's going to
look like an x to people
how are people going to distinguish it
from an x and he had a good point there
but uh in fact the time stein has
survived even despite that ambiguity
so the history of mathematical notation
and these conventions about mathematics
is a story very similar to the history
of natural language
uh where it was in things were
introduced
things took you know took took on
um became popular and so on there was
some amount of design done
um i think we know a lot more now about
how to design
computational language i like to think
we do and so
many of the things many of the mistakes
that could have been made in the past we
wouldn't make today
an example where uh was something of a
mistake where
where you're defining uh was a language
called apl
developed by a person called ken
iverston in the 1960s and a little bit
beyond
which was an attempt to kind of provide
a notation for algorithmic kinds of
operations
and he invented a very large number of
new sort of symbols like plus signs and
time signs except he'd have
you know a triangle up with a line
through it and he'd have
some kind of different kinds of greek
like letters
slightly modified and so on and the
problem was
that there were a lot of good and
interesting ideas
but there were just too many that came
too quickly and people just didn't learn
them and couldn't understand them
and when you first see it for the first
time it looks like
some weird hieroglyphic script so to
speak that you
you couldn't possibly imagine decoding
but uh okay that that's um
a little bit um uh comments on um
why math has an order of operations uh
there's some let's see yeah
that's probably that's probably the
okay so so one of the other issues
actually which i'm slightly
sliding over is that when you say uh
something like uh one over two
one slash two slash three one feature of
that is that the slash operation
always has two arguments you're always
dividing this by that
for plus it can actually be an enery
operator
where you have any number of things all
being added together
sort of together you could you can
decompose it as
you're adding the first two things
together then you're adding one more
onto that
thing that you've already made then
you're adding one more to that so it can
be decomposed
into a series of binary operations plus
has the property that it is associative
so it doesn't matter whether it's been
decomposed into those binary operations
or not
um that there's it doesn't matter in
which order you decompose it you could
you could arrange the parentheses in
different ways and you'll still get the
same answer
for plus because plus has this property
of associativity
it is not the case that these different
operations
have the feature that it matters to the
answer whether you do
in the example with plus and times
whether you do the plus the times before
the plus
or the other way around that matters to
the answer
you can invent kind of operations in
mathematics where it doesn't matter what
the order is
just like the example of plus that i
just gave it doesn't matter the answer
that you'll get
by doing this addition is the same
regardless of of how you do how you
collect the numbers together
and so you can you can set up
mathematical operations which have this
feature that doesn't matter what order
you do the kind of collecting together
in but
the ones that are typically useful in
mathematics
only some of them have that feature and
they don't have that feature relative to
each
other so to speak and by the way when
you do have that feature
it has a lot of very cool consequences
when you do have this feature you can
sort of do it in any
um you can sort of collect the things
together in any order
it has a big consequence in the amount
of
in in how you actually do computations
because it allows you to kind of clump
pieces of computations together and
often something where
it would take you for example let's say
you have n things that you have to do
something with
it might take you n squared operations
to do it if you had to do sort of each
piece separately
because you can clump in different ways
you can reduce that to n log n to much
faster computation
so that that kind of ability to
associate and clump things
in different ways is pretty important in
in practical computation
but in general you could imagine a
mathematics where the order of
operations never matters because
all the operators that you deal with
sort of have this property that they
sort of associate to distribute over
each other and so on
but that's not the mathematics that we
actually have and you can ask the
question
uh well why isn't it and that's
something that
once you have things like integers whole
numbers and you're doing
so so the operations that you do on
integers you might say plus
times power where do these come from why
are they the natural operations to do
there's actually a very good reason for
that which is
if you say two plus two plus two
you do it three times well iterated
addition
two plus two plus two three times is
three times two so in other words
multiplication
is iterated addition what's iterated
multiplication
2 times 2 times 2 that's a power that's
2 to the power 3.
so it's a very natural sequence the the
beginning of the sequence is the pure
successor operation
just add one to an integer very basic
operation on integers
and that's and so repeated successoring
is addition so you're saying plus one
plus one plus one plus one a bunch of
times
and that's that's so your your
let's see how does this work when you do
uh yeah but basically
you're you're you're you're successoring
multiple times that makes an integer
you keep successoring that makes that
adds another integer to it
so in a sentence addition is repeated
successoring
um and um multiplication is repeated
addition
power is a repeated multiplication you
can ask what are repeated powers
that would be like saying 2 to the 2 to
the 2 to the 2
some number of times that operation is
sometimes called power towers
sometimes called tetration and things
get very big very quickly like 2 to the
2
is 4 2 to the 2 to the 2 remember that
we're grouping them as
2 to the 2 to the 2. so 2 to the 4 which
is 16
um and then the next thing up would be
uh
2 to the 2 to the 16 which is 2 to the
power 65
2 to the power 64 000 roughly that's a
pretty big number
and the 2 to the 2 to the 2 the 2 to the
2 thing grows very very quickly
so you might ask can you make a function
which just says
do uh like you go from from plus to
times to power to tetration
what's next well you can do integrated
tetration as well
you can actually make a function that
where one of the parameters in the
function is
is how deeply to nest this process
actually the most common version of this
is the thing called the ackermann
function
which was invented around 1920 and uh
it it's a function where one argument is
basically says how many times to nest
and the other is what to put in it so it
will give you things like two to the two
to the to the two
or it'll give you two plus two plus two
plus two plus two depending on whether
it's first
argument is saying just do the one level
pluses or the next level timeses or the
next level powers or the tetration
whatever else and that that function is
sort of an important counter example to
various things
because it's a very rapidly growing
function as you can guess from
from the way i've defined it but it's
sort of inevitable
by the time you've integers that you
will have to have
orders of operations that differ between
these different layers
in this kind of hierarchy of iterated
kinds of operations
okay well let's see
there's a question here from ardol
what does a day in the life of a
scientist look like
it depends a little bit what kind of
scientist
let's break it down between experimental
scientists
and theoretical scientists so
experimental scientists
the uh
the big point is do an experiment and
make it work so you might be building
apparatus you might be doing electronics
you might be
putting together some complicated pieces
of glassware you might be um
doing those kinds of things to try to
set up your apparatus
then what tends to be more and more
the story of doing science is you get
data it arrives in your computer and you
have to analyze it
and so you're doing lots of kind of data
analysis
and one of the things that to realize
about doing
well many kinds of science but
particularly experimental science
is you know any any serious experiment
is going to take quite a while
so on any given day it's very unlikely
that you're going to be saying aha i
made a great discovery today
you'll be building up some whole
activity
that you'll be setting up this
experiment and so on and so on and so on
it might take you weeks months
uh if it's a big experiment in some big
area of physics or something
it might take five years to set up the
experiment and it might involve 100
people
setting up the experiment and um you
know
it might be some giant thing that costs
hundreds of millions of dollars
um or it might be a table top kind of
experiment but where again you have to
sort of gradually build it up
build up the experiment and so on and
then you start taking data and you
realize oh there was this thing wrong
and
the thing doesn't work quite right i
have to change it
i analyze the data i see it isn't quite
right i change it etc etc etc
eventually you may get results
and then there's the question of you
know making sure the results are correct
not you know one of the traps is always
you think you're going to get such and
such a result
you keep tweaking your experiment
eventually you get that result you say
ah i'm done
well maybe you're not because actually
maybe that was wrong and you've just
been tweaking lots of tweaks
you got it to the point where you got
what you expect but you should keep
checking it to make sure it really was
right but
i think a decent fraction i don't know
what fraction i would guess
it's probably you know average average
of experimental scientists probably
two-thirds of the time is spent doing
data analysis of one kind or another
which means uh you know how do you how
do you
take get the signal out of the data how
do you find that signal
from all of this kind of randomness in
the data things like that
that's typical experimental science kind
of thing theoretical science
is well again uh it some people do it
in a very kind of pencil and paper type
way of i'm just going to think about
this i'm going to write notes
and you know sort of do it by hand and
so on
i think very much increasingly and this
has been a thing that
kind of i've provided the tools for in
my life i suppose
is is doing these things by computer and
being able to
do experiments on a computer where
you're you're setting up some program
and you're saying
this program represents the thing i'm
trying to figure out this program
represents my model
for how this particular system in nature
might work or something
now let me run this program and see what
happens and so
a large fraction of the time is spent uh
making uh you know programs running the
programs trying to understand the
results of those programs and so on
and some part of the time
is spent just like in experimental
science it's kind of like
designing what you're going to do
understanding the results you get
making conclusions from that it's it's
pretty rare
i mean when i do science for example i
managed to spend quite a lot of my time
doing essentially conceptual thinking
um and sort of figuring things out at a
level
i mean for me i i i find it really
useful to do actual
examples and the fact that i'm very
fluent in actually doing computer
experiments
is super useful and much to be
recommended for people
interested in theoretical science um
because it's
that's what you need and similarly with
experimental science being really fluent
in computational language to do data
analysis and so on
that's really an important thing because
you know the question is where you've
got this data and you're like well i
just
wonder whether if i if i've studied this
correlation of that
whether i would see something well if
it's going to take you a week
to study this correlation with that
you're like oh i can't be bothered i
probably don't know what i'm talking
about but if it's going to if you're
fluent enough that's going to take you
15 minutes
you try it and by golly that might be
the great discovery
so to speak so it's really important to
be fluent in these tools
and i think people um you know that
seems to be an increasing dividing line
in terms of effectiveness and science
these days
but then you know in in if you're an
actual scientist you eventually have to
explain what you're doing to other
people
that means you're writing papers and
things like that
i have to say that in my experience it's
worthwhile
starting to write the description of
what you're doing pretty early
because it helps you to understand it
yourself you have to know
so the main results you're getting but
then you start trying to write about it
and usually in the process of writing
about it
you'll understand it more clearly you'll
get more results
um and then in terms of
uh well and now it breaks down in terms
of what kind of science you do if you're
an academic doing science
typically your average academic
scientist is a professor
who makes a living by teaching students
and so that's a part of people's lives
um there's also
kind of the whole dynamic of uh going to
scientific conferences and interacting
with other scientists and so on
and presenting your work and uh uh
that that's sort of another another
piece of the process of being a
scientist
and and so sometimes there's kind of a
um you know
a perk for scientists like there are
often you know in in the days when there
are
in-person conferences there are
conferences you know scattered all over
the world and
there are people who will spend that
time you know particularly during the
summer hopping from one
exotic location to another going to
scientific conferences
um i i think it's people find that quite
a lot of fun and
and um uh there's sort of a groups of
people in different fields who will
frequent the different conferences and
so on it's quite a
sort of social scene it it i mean
there's much more to say about
kind of the the what it feels like to do
science but i would say that the
the thing to realize is uh doing science
from a research point of view is a
little bit similar but not that similar
to doing science
in an educational kind of i'm going to
do the exercises in the textbook kind of
way
because one feature of exercises in
textbooks is you know they've got
answers
it isn't the case that you might get in
some direction where you're
you're going and it's like oh my gosh
there may just not be any way to answer
this question
because nobody's ever done it before and
when you do research
you're constantly in this well maybe
nobody actually answered this and
and maybe there just isn't an answer
maybe in the current state
of whatever it is mathematics physics
science whatever
maybe we just can't answer this question
maybe we have to come back in 50 years
and then we might be able to answer it
you never know and so it's something
where
it takes a big part of the skill of
doing research
well is to have some idea what's going
to be answerable what's not
what are the right kinds of things to
study what are the questions which are
going to
potentially have interesting answers
rather than having answers where
the answer is oh well it depends there
isn't a definite answer type thing
and then once you have some idea of of
what the answer
uh what what what what might be worth
answering
the question is what kind of rough
methods might you use
are there methods you already know are
there methods you have to go and learn
um are they uh is it going to be
something where this is going to be a
huge project and you're making a huge
commitment to try and study this
or is it going to be something where
you're just going to do it there's a
little bit of fun that's going to take
you a couple of weeks and maybe you'll
get a good result or not
so those are those are some of the kinds
of things
i i would say that for me personally in
so far as i
do science my my life day in the life
as a scientist is probably very
un-typical because i'm not
for example i'm not a professor type i
instead i'm a tech company ceo so the
the part of my time that isn't doing
basic science is doing
uh designing products and languages and
running companies and things like this
um
but for me uh the you know i can usually
you know like this morning actually i
i had a a uh um i started my day a
little bit earlier than usual so i
didn't have an initial meeting so i
spent an hour
doing uh doing science what did that
actually mean
well i was writing a piece of code to
try and figure out something
that i had sort of a partial answer to
and i didn't quite finish during the
hour that i had available
and i wrote this wolfram language
notebook that kind of explains what i
was doing so that i can remember
what i did and uh i have sort of a a
partially finished result
that was looking like it was going in a
really interesting direction and it
looks some
i'm very i'm very enthusiastic about it
but i didn't have a chance to work on it
yet
um i'll probably have a chance uh later
today or tomorrow to work on it
um and i think that's uh uh but you know
one of the things to realize about doing
science you know i've been lucky enough
to be able to do
science with good tools and sometimes
with good strategy about what to study
and that means the rate of discovering
things can can be quite high
but one of the things it's it's a funny
business because
you might think i mean i
i suppose that if you kind of
uh uh if you watch me doing these things
and
in fact i i do a sort of this this
horribly archival thing of recording a
bunch of the video
from my uh from my computer screen when
i'm working on stuff
just because i think it's kind of fun uh
to record what actually was involved in
in figuring things out and a lot of what
you'll see is kind of writing code
debugging code writing
uh comments about things making various
kinds of
uh jotting down various kinds of ideas
things like this
but somehow it's very uh
you know there'll be some moment when
something gets discovered
but often you don't even know when that
moment was because you don't have quite
the right context to know
that was important or something happens
and it's very surprising
and the question is is that a discovery
or did i make a mistake somewhere
or am i confused about something and
it's not something where you say
look i discovered something wow
that happens occasionally but more often
it's something unexpected happens
let me try and figure out what's going
on is it a mistake
is it a confusion or is it a discovery
and so
that that sort of blunts the moment of
aha i just made a discovery this instant
type thing
although that can happen too and
particularly when it comes to sort of
understanding how things fit together
that can be something where for me at
least there's sort of a moment when
when that discovery gets made and
usually for me
uh sometimes i make that discovery as
i'm trying to write or describe what's
going on that's
for me a very useful way to sort of uh
uh
unravel what's happening
there's a question here about uh what's
my opinion about reproducible research
well so one of the issues is when you're
doing experimental science for example
it's do you if
you say if i feed the mouse
this kind of chemical then the mouse
will be able to do the maze twice as
fast
let's say and you observe that with one
mouse
a mouse named fred let's say that that
happens
okay uh if if you did if you used fred
the next day
would the same thing happen if you used
uh
jane instead would the same thing happen
if you used um
you know how reproducible is this
experiment how much is this the case
that every time you feed the mouse this
particular thing the mouse gets smarter
at doing the maze
or is that something that just happened
once
so it's important in making kind of
solid conclusions in science
that things be reproducible not least
because
there may be circumstances it may be
that the that
why did the mouse do the maze twice as
fast well maybe it's because
it was um let's say
it did the maze the second time in the
evening rather than in the
in the afternoon rather than in the
morning and the second time it did the
maze the sun was shining through the lab
window
and illuminated this different thing and
so the mouse could see the end of the
maze more quickly
i'm making all of this up just as an
example um
and and so something you didn't know you
didn't notice that oh you did all those
experiments in the afternoon
and all those other ones in the morning
but in fact
that feature is what made the experiment
come out the way it came out
and it had nothing to do with what the
mouse had eaten and so
that that's a reason to want to do
reproducible experiments
to say i could give that i could
somebody else's lab to do the same
experiment
and their mouse maze will be placed in a
different place and they'll have
different
sort of other factors contributing and
yet they still get the same answer we
just discovered
the make the mouse twice as smart drug
or something
um in uh in in this in this experiment
and and it's now a reproducible thing
that you can take it anywhere
and reproduce it so so that's a it tends
to be an important thing and when there
are results
which are not reproducible people
sometimes say ah
not interesting not reproducible that's
probably a mistake too
because there's some pretty major kinds
of things that people have studied where
they're really remarkable phenomena
really remarkable and surprising effects
where they only happened a few times
and they only happen in some particular
person's lab and everybody else says oh
nobody can reproduce that
must be nonsense it's probably not
always the right conclusion sometimes
it'll be the right conclusion but often
it's not the right conclusion
often it's just like you didn't think of
the critical thing
which yes the person originally did the
experiment didn't list that
as one of the things that is a feature
of how they did the experiment but
actually it turns out to be the critical
thing
that you know some particular i don't
know you know that
the fact that the lab was in denver not
at sea level was the critical thing and
nobody knew that and uh or something you
know and that was the fact that it only
happened in the lab in denver
well you know you shouldn't just say oh
the person did the experiment must have
must have got it wrong it's like well
maybe there was something we didn't
think of
that makes that experiment come out that
way and another one not come out that
way
so it's a tricky thing now it's also
worth saying that when you do computer
experiments
most of the time they're just
reproducible because you have a program
you run it it does the same thing if you
have random numbers
if that then people sometimes get a bit
confused about this
you can which are chosen by the computer
for example then yes you run at
different times the random numbers can
be different like when you do machine
learning it's pretty common that you're
kind of using lots of random numbers
to pick things and so things can come
out differently but you can always
on a computer you can always see the
random numbers say
i'm going to use this procedure for
making random numbers and i'm always
going to get the same sequence of random
numbers
because i seeded the procedure the same
way and so then it becomes reproducible
but so typically with computer
experiments reproducibility is not
really a problem
the uh that's something i i found it
amusing when i
when i publish my big book called a new
kind of science that's full of computer
experiments
and people are saying this experiment
must be wrong and it's like
what do you mean you just run the thing
you know here's the code
here's the here's the you know here's
the rule that's being used
just run it you get the answer now
that's all well and good if the if the
program that you're running is one that
you as a human can read and it's
in some nice computational language and
so on it can also be the case
that things can go wrong in computer
experiments
because you can have this giant uh
program and there's a bug in it and it
doesn't do what you expect it to do
so if you're doing sort of pure sort of
studies of the computational universe
typically the question is what does this
program do
and the program is the program you have
and there's no notion of a bug in the
program because what you're actually
studying
is the program itself but like famously
when people were studying supernovas
exploding stars back in the 1970s and
1980s
there were these giant computer codes
that were supposed to represent all the
nuclear reactions that were happening in
stars
and those computer codes said oh whoops
stars will collapse and not explode they
couldn't explain supernovas
and eventually that was traced to a bug
just a typing mistake basically in this
big program
that had been used to study supernovas
and so that was an example of where
the it was perfectly reproducible you
could run the program as many times as
you want and
you would end up with them with
the same wrong answer because uh because
of this bug in the program
now in terms of reproducibility of of
lab experiments
one of the things that's happening is
the increasing automation of of
of labs i mean that a lot of times still
in in biology in chemistry labs
there's been um uh you know people tend
to do things with ha
by hand you know there'll be a pipette
you you you know pipet
some some liquid from one thing to
another and you you put it in these
different
uh uh you know uh uh
you know 96 well plates or whatever else
it is
and you're doing a lot of stuff still by
hand but there also
are machines that are that are
doing i don't know dna sequencing or
whatever else
and increasingly there's an increasing
level of automation
in labs and the more things are
automated the more they will tend
to be quite reproducible actually
there's i should give a shout out to a
company that uses our technology a lot
called emerald cloud lab that's
basically
has the mission of completely automating
biology and chemistry labs and they have
a very
impressive facility of full of uh you
know robots and things
for um for just going from
essentially a software specification in
welcome language of an experiment that
you want to do
and then you know you press go and
you know things swing into action and
with the
uh the experiment is automatically and
reproducibly done
now so that's a it's an example i think
one will see that as i think that will
be a very successful effort
and what we'll see increasingly in
biomedical kinds of papers
there'll just be a wolfram language
script that just says this is the
experiment that was done
and it's not kind of a description in
words it's just a script
and you take that script and you run it
on your sort of
any instance of the emerald cloud lab
and it'll get the same result
and that's sort of i think going to be
an important thing for reproducibility
in biomedical science
because it's not doesn't depend on oh
how well did you perpet that thing and
so on
it's done by a machine which can have
you know well-defined quality control
and all those kinds of things there's a
one different issue about
reproducibility
which has to do with situations where
uh for whatever reason you think there's
sort of randomness coming into the
system so a classic example
is in fluid flow let's say you you drop
some a drop of ink
into some water you make this very
elaborate pattern
of sort of the ink flowing around and so
on the question is
if you do that ink dropping another time
is it going to be the same pattern
well if you do it carefully enough it
will be the same pattern
but some things people believe it's
essentially impossible to do it
carefully enough to make it be the same
pattern
they believe that it matters what kind
of which position in the fluid which
exact molecule
in that little ink drop was involved
in in making it produce this pattern all
that and there's a whole
idea usually goes under the name of
chaos theory
um that has to do with sensitive
dependence on initial conditions the
possibility that
if you just change by this tiny tiny
amount
one part in a trillion trillion trillion
exactly where that ink drop
falls that eventually as the as the
whole pattern develops
that eventually some feature of that
pattern will depend on that
trillion trillion trillionth part of
exactly how the thing was started off
and people have believed that sort of
some of the complexity of things you see
in nature can be attributed to that
dependence on the trillion trillion part
or whatever it is
i think that's actually not really right
that effect does happen but it's quite
rare
and the effect that's much more common
is that systems
will produce complicated behavior but
they will do so in a reproducible way
it's like you know when you compute the
digits of pi
you know it's three point one four one
five nine two six etcetera etcetera
etcetera
that digit sequence is quite random
but yet every time you compute it it
will be the same
and i think that's more what's going on
in a lot of these systems
in nature if you do the experiment
carefully enough it will be reproducible
you don't don't have to get it
reproduced at the kind of molecular or
quantum type level
to be able to to get the same result
i should explain if i'm really going to
be complete in answering this question
about reproducibility
i should talk about quantum mechanics
and i should talk about the fact that
in quantum mechanics there's this idea
that when you make a measurement that
all that the theory can tell you
is what the probability of something
happening is going to be
it doesn't tell you what specific thing
will happen and that's sort of a
a necessary kind of non-reproducibility
but in our theory of physics
that story becomes considerably more
complicated in terms of how you
interpret it
and in terms of the way that we as
observers of the universe
uh this this is going to get complicated
to describe this
but i think it's fair to say that that
there is a
a notion of reproducibility
of what in our theory would be called
the multi-way graph
this is sort of the graph of all
possible quantum histories
that that can be reproducible but the
particular observation
that a particular observer makes because
that observer
has certain arbitrariness about sort of
how they're observing what's going on
what they see may not be reproducible
even though what's in a sense
fundamentally there
is reproducible but that's a that's a
significantly more complicated
uh kind of question
um
let's see
all right there's a question here
[Music]
um
there's a comment here okay this is a
more um
uh actually just put
live on the web i might might comment i
did some
as part of our annual summer school i
did some interviews with some
scientists and others um
that were initially just intended for
our summer school students but
the interviews were kind of interesting
and so we put them out on the web
um and you'll find the first set of
maybe five or so of them that are out
there
and i'm actually planning to do a weekly
kind of interview with
uh some interesting
scientists i have to say that i have a
very
uh sort of personal objective with these
interviews which is i'm trying to learn
stuff from them
and i hope the interviews will be
interesting and other people will learn
things too
but my number one objective and my
number one criterion for for picking
people to talk to
is really things that are sort of in the
path of things that i'm trying to
research and i'm trying to understand
because that kind of gives me a a among
other things that that's
well that's as i say my personal
objective there
and also gives me a particular kind of
direction for
um uh for what what uh if one talks to
somebody who's been
doing interesting science all their life
so to speak uh
there's there's there's too much to talk
about
in an hour um and so i'm i will be
trying to focus these things based on
particular things that that i'm
interested in
um so let's see
uh
there's a question here um
wow okay there's a question from carob
will teleportation ever be possible
and even if only say for a photon
stream someone could send a probe into a
black hole and be able to transmit back
images across the event horizon or
something
okay let's explain what teleportation is
um
teleportation is you're here now
instantaneously you're somewhere else
a moment later so
you can clearly go from here to
somewhere else
by just you know walking there
or getting in a spacecraft and going
there but that takes a bunch of time
the question is can you instantaneously
show up
on the other side of the earth or show
up on the other side of the galaxy
or whatever else is it possible to
uh do something that's like in you know
the star trek transporter
kind of idea where you're you're one
place
and then you're suddenly somewhere else
now it's worth commenting that even
sort of the junior version of
teleportation might be
you're here now you travel at the speed
of light to somewhere else
and then you are then you show up at
that other place
right now if we take light photons
making up light
they're always traveling at the speed of
light but
we made of ordinary atoms and ordinary
matter and so on
we don't go at the speed of light we are
made of particles that have
mass photons have zero mass zero mass
things go at the speed of light
non-zero mass things just kind of sit
there unless
you push them very hard then they'll go
then they you can push them
and and it's it's actually as you try
and make them go faster and faster
what one of the consequences of
relativity theory is that
as you try and make something go closer
and closer to the speed of light
the amount of force with which you have
to push the thing
increases dramatically as you get closer
to the speed of light
and in fact you'll never reach the speed
of light with any finite force for any
massive object
you'll be pushing harder and harder and
harder i think it's going faster and
faster and faster
like the fastest things we do on earth
with particles
are in particle accelerators and there
we take things like protons
and we accelerate them to 99.99
whatever percent of the speed of light
they are the fastest things on on earth
other than photons are the particles in
a particle accelerator and uh
that's um and so you might say
well gee why don't you just take you
know you
and sort of put you in a particle
accelerator and wind you up somewhere
else
well the problem is the only things we
have in particle accelerators are
individual protons
going around so unless you want to be
disintegrated into individual protons
you're kind of out of luck in a particle
accelerator
now the question is well what if you
could
uh let's say that you wanted to teleport
a lump of plastic okay well
here's how you could do that you could
have a 3d scanner
and it could figure out what the
geometry of that plastic is
you could turn that geometry you could
just send the signal that says
here's the geometry you could send it by
uh
you know a radio or something at speed
of light
and at the other end there's a 3d
printer and it prints out that um
that same shaped lump of plastic so in a
sense you've teleported that piece of
plastic
uh in the sense that you took the a
version of that piece of plastic and
maybe
maybe for extra uh sort of for extra
teleportation points you can destroy
the original piece of plastic and then
it's as if you started with this one
piece of plastic
you did all those things to it it at the
speed of light you moved it somewhere
else
it was reconstituted there that's
actually i think in the
in the kind of backstory to star trek i
think the transporter
the concept there is it's sort of
breaking things down into individual
atoms
sending the information about those
atoms and reconstituting at the other
end that's kind of the
science fiction backstory to that so
that's one sort of form of teleportation
we don't know how to do it except for
things like lumps of plastic
right now maybe in the future when we
have molecular scale manufacturing
when we can actually construct an
arbitrary collection of atoms arranged
in molecules and all those kinds of
things
maybe when we can do that which i think
will be possible at some point in the
future
to do kind of molecular scale
construction sort of atom by atom
we can do that in very simple cases
right now with atomic force microscopes
with an atomic force microscope you can
basically pick up an individual
atom of uh i don't know skeleton or
something and put it down in a different
place
it's rather slow to do it because you're
doing it atom at a time that's not the
best way to build things
but still we can we can more or less do
that but it requires being on solid
surfaces and all that kind of thing
the idea of just being able to say
here's a design
here's a you know i've drawn out my
design for the molecule i want press go
make that molecule we can't do that for
arbitrary molecules we
there's another special case where we
can do it which is for dna
we know how to make small sequences of
dna reasonably small
sequences of dna with arbitrary
sequences of base pairs
and the big thing that sort of life
discovered
is how to take a dna sequence
and use it to make proteins sequences of
amino acids that then are molecules of
different shapes and so on
but we don't know how to do that in more
generality than the particular
of the thing that's been discovered by
the evolution of life on earth namely
the dna
rna amino acid protein type type
sequence
but so maybe one day we will be able to
reconstruct things at a molecular scale
and kind of the scan it get
figure out where every atom is send the
information about that reconstitute the
other end that's one
kind of form of of sort of junior
teleportation let's say
the other form of teleportation is
something where literally
the the actual somehow the actual
thing winds up in a different place at
let's say zero at infinite speed rather
than just at the speed of light
okay so one of the places where this
gets confusing is in quantum mechanics
there is a notion of teleportation
and and here's roughly how that works
the
sort of this the story of classical
mechanics is always
that definite things happen in the
universe you
uh drop a stone it falls in a definite
trajectory
in quantum mechanics the story is
instead of definite things happening
like that all possible things happen
so you drop a stone and actually there
are all these different possible paths
that stone could follow
they're all in some sense followed and
the typical way we observe quantum
mechanics
is through um kind of uh
our particular sampling of that
set of possible quantum histories so
the the the thing that um and what we've
understood
actually from our physics project is a
lot about how that sort of structure of
quantum histories works
um it's it's a rather elaborate thing
where there's sort of
at any moment you can have one state of
the universe it can branch into two
those can branch again but then
different branches can sometimes
merge different histories of the
universe could end up actually in the
same state of the universe
and that branching and merging
phenomenon it's a very important
phenomenon
that leads to this kind of quantum
entanglement phenomenon
but the main thing is there's branching
and merging of all these different
possible histories for the universe
very confusingly when we are observing
the universe
our brains are effectively branching and
merging in the same kind of way
so the story of quantum mechanics and
quantum measurement ends up being a
story of how does a branching brain
perceive a branching universe and that's
a tricky thing
and you can represent it using some of
the mathematics
uh some fairly advanced mathematics
that's kind of
been uh emerging from pure mathematics
and from cat
from from uh from quantum mechanics in
in recent years and it's now rather
clarified in
in our project but um uh so
okay what happens is in that kind of
multi-way graph of all these possible
quantum histories
you can sort of lay out the possible
quantum histories at a particular moment
in time
when i say lay them out you're not
laying them out in ordinary space
you're laying them out in what we call
bronchial space the space of possible
quantum branches
and that branchial space has many
attributes like
physical space but it isn't physical
space and so
one of the attributes that it has is
just like in physical space the
fastest you can go is the speed of light
in branchial space the fastest you can
go is a new thing that we've
realized which is this maximum
entanglement speed we don't know how big
the maximum entanglement speed is
we think it might be around it's in
weird units around 100 000 solar masses
per second
um but uh that that's in weird units
because the the
the the notion of distance in branchial
space is kind of
it's not measured in meters it's
measured in other kinds of units
so in any case the um
uh so there's this maximum speed in
bronchial space
it's it's a it's some value but it has
nothing directly to do with the speed of
light and physical space
so what can happen is in quantum
mechanics
you can end up with something where
different branches in branchial space
have wound up different in different
places in branch hill space
corresponding to different places and
those different outcomes have
have some object to different places in
physical space
and so well it's kind of a long story
but but um you can
end up with something where
with respect to the measurements you do
you will appear to have teleported
something
from one place to another in when you
try and
sort of trace back what information had
to get exchanged
in order to know what measurements to do
you actually have to have sort of a back
channel
that exchanges information through
physical space
at kind of the speed of light but
nevertheless you can
you can do the um uh
the the this teleportation protocol
will allow you if you have that back
channel information exchanged
then uh which can only happen at speed
of light
then other things can happen seemingly
instantaneously
although we think actually it isn't
really instantaneous it's actually
something related to this maximum
entanglement speed and it will be
interesting to try to measure that and
that's a that's a whole different story
but so that's kind of a notion of
teleportation that happens there
and i don't think that that is um that's
more of a kind of
a trick of how the measurement process
works and how these kind of branching
brains in in quantum measurement work
then it is an actual i'm going to move
this from here to there
now there are other effects uh one
this is kind of tricky when
in our models space so in the usual
thinking about space
it's just like space is just a place
where you put stuff you can say
i'm going to put something in this
position in space i'm going to put
something in this position in space
there's no question of sort of what
space is made of in our models
space like a fluid like water is made of
molecules
so space is made of a whole collection
of discrete points that we can kind of
kind of somewhat whimsically called
atoms of space
they're not real atoms they're something
much more conceptual
they're just geometrical points that
define the content of space
okay so what what then can happen is and
this is now going to get a bit tricky
but but what then can happen is
there's this question of of what does it
take
uh well i wrote this whole piece
actually last year
about um faster than light travel in our
models
and um i i think this would take me a
while to explain how this works but well
i'll give it a try
so okay how is space what is space made
of
space is all these points and these
points have connectivity information
each point
knows which other points it's so to
speak friends with
it knows which points are related to
which other points
and that's how we define all of space
and
the notion that we can kind of think of
space as this thing which is
laid out and where we go from here to
there to the next place that's all
sort of emerging from a large number
of of different geometrical points with
all these different connections
okay and the way it works is at every
moment
space is being recreated there are
little updates that are happening if
those connections are getting changed to
other connections
and every moment everywhere in space
there are those updates happening
if it wasn't for those updates space
would not be knitted together
we wouldn't be able to have a notion of
adjacent pieces of space and things like
this
that's a consequence of continuing
activity in space
and in a sense most of the activity of
the universe is actually the maintenance
of space
all the things that we're familiar with
you know electrons and quarks and all
those kinds of things
those are just some you know trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth
piece of everything that's going on in
the universe most of what's going on in
the universe
is essentially the maintenance of space
and
in a sense if we were to if we had a way
to look at it sort of microscopically
what we would see is that it's like kind
of molecules and a gas they're all just
bouncing around
but together they have the effect of
making this gas and it has a certain
pressure and so on
similarly we would see all these atoms
of space doing very complicated things
but together they make something which
kind of seems like space as we
experience
it okay so tricky thing is
let's imagine we're just looking at
molecules of gas in a room
and we say i want to go i want to ride a
molecule
from one side of the room to the other
okay so most of the time
in in air for example at standard
pressure the mean free path of an atom a
molecule is very short
so most of the time most air molecules
will go
uh a tiny tiny distance before they hit
another air molecule and then they'll
hit another air molecule and so on
and as they they each time they hit a
molecule they'll be probably
sent in a random direction and so if
you're writing an air molecule it's
going to follow this kind of random walk
from one side of the room to the other
it's going to kind of just uh
and that means that it's going to go
rather slowly from one side of the room
to the other because sometimes they'll
go forwards a step
they'll go take one step forward one
step sideways one step back and so on
and the average distance that you go
after a time
t is about square root of t doesn't it
it it goes slowly
okay well but if you were very clever
and you could kind of see all the
molecules in the room
and you could pick particular molecules
you'd say okay i'm going to go on this
molecule
for this micron distance then i'm going
to hop to this other molecule i'm going
to write it for the next micron
and then this molecule and then this
molecule i'm going to predict exactly
what sequence of molecules i should
follow
well then you will not be subject to
this kind of random walk
you'll be able to pick a series of
molecules you'll be able to kind of
pick these stepping stone molecules and
you're able to be able to hop across the
room
actually at the speed molecules go out
which is basically the speed of sound
so if you were clever enough at the
level of molecules
you would be able to hop molecule to
molecule and
travel through the air at the speed of
sound just by
writing molecules okay now in practice
we can't do that
because the we have it's very hard to
foresee what all the molecules are going
to do
and we don't have things at the scale of
individual molecules and it's just
completely impractical
but it turns out that well
there is the same kind of behind a
possibility in space
there are just as this kind of all these
interactions in atoms of space and so on
if we pick the exact right ones to be
associated with
we could go at something which is
actually more than
the speed of light the speed of light is
more or less the speed
that would correspond it doesn't
correspond it's okay there's
there's some confusing aspects to this
whole thing about about the analogy
between gas molecules and atoms of space
they're not
quite as analogous as i'm making it
sound but but roughly
the um there's a there's a speed of
light
that is the sort of the average speed
that the average maximum speed that
things go at
but there is the possibility if you pick
the exact
right sort of atoms of space to ride
that you could go
faster than the speed of light um and uh
that uh yeah i'm i'm a lighting a bunch
of things about the way that space is
actually made
and you're sort of you're sort of
beating the way that space is knitted
you're finding these kind of
tunnels and space uh that uh sort of go
outside of the kind of main structure
of space but that allows you to do
things where you're going
essentially faster than the speed of
light and so if you could if you could
make use of those space tunnels you
could teleport
and the one of the things people talk
about in
traditional ideas about about the
structure of spacetime
are these things called wormholes you
can't
create a wormhole in the standard theory
of relativity
you can in our models of physics because
they
they have more detailed information
about the structure of space-time
and so they allow you to understand how
you can actually create
a thing which has kind of holes in it
and so on from a thing that doesn't you
can't understand that
in the traditional theory of relativity
and traditional general activity
but in any case the in traditional
general relativity you can have these
wormholes
which are kind of ways in which you can
go like a worm can have a hole from one
sort of piece of soil to another you're
going from
one piece of space-time to another piece
of space-time
sort of in a different path than than
the traditional one where you're just
going through every every intermediate
step in space-time
one of the downers about wormholes in
traditional relativity
is that to maintain a wormhole you need
a negative mass thing
you need negative energy you need
something where gravity
is not attractive as it usually is with
positive mass things
you need something where its mass is
negative so that it can have repulsive
gravity
um that is needed to sort of hold the
wormhole open
um but in traditional in traditional
models
the only way you get a wormhole is to
already have a wormhole in our models
you can create
space tunnels which are a little bit
different from wormholes they're a
little bit of a generalization of
wormholes
you can create them without having one
to begin with and in fact
constantly in the as space
evolves there will be little tiny space
tunnels produced
all over the place whether you can line
them all up to make something you can
travel through as a different issue
but so that's kind of a a you know we're
very far away from the technology for
being able to do these things
whether that technology is conceivable
to make uh
in our universe i don't really know um
but never say never
in terms of what is technologically
possible
um it uh many things even in my lifetime
i think of gravitational wave detection
for example where um
it's like well we'll never be able to
observe it but then one can
actually another effect that's kind of
fun that i was
uh uh you know we i talked about the
the things that go fastest the the
forms of matter that go fastest on our
planet are in particle accelerators
so there are protons whizzing at very
close to the speed of light around
particle accelerators
gravitational waves are produced when
massive objects kind of accelerate
in in certain ways and in fact there
will be gravitational waves produced by
particle accelerators
there's a thing called synchrotron
radiation which is a usually
electromagnetic radiation
that uh comes about when you are making
a particle stay
in a circular path because to make it
stay in a circular path
uh it has to be accelerated because if
it wasn't being accelerated it would
just keep going in a straight line
and and that process of of keeping it
accelerating it will emit this thing
called synchrotron radiation
the usual synchrotron radiation is
electromagnetic radiation it's gamma
rays x-rays things like that
but there will also be gravitational
synchrotron radiation
a tiny uh amount of gravitational
radiation
actually i think on the surface of the
earth
the biggest source of gravitational
radiation is probably protons
in particle accelerators um and but that
right now looks like a ridiculously
immeasurably small amount of
gravitational radiation
i'm sure that in time it will become
possible to actually measure that
um and that's uh just an example of sort
of the progress of these things that at
first
seem like they're just sort of too small
in effect to ever be important
um and but then it turns out that
eventually one can
one can measure them and sometimes even
make use of them for
for technology
well i think um we're getting to the end
of our time here today
um uh
so many interesting questions all right
well i think we have to leave these for
um
another time i might say for people
who are um
uh who find these answers interesting
um the um
uh we have been posting
previous iterations
of these live streams um and actually
through some nice technology that we
have there are word clouds generated
from the transcripts from the automated
transcripts
of the things i've been talking about so
you can kind of see if you scan
through the the uh the episodes you can
kind of see what types of questions were
being addressed
in them and actually the uh sort of uh
shortened versions of the questions
themselves where we're adding in
to those um uh uh to that
to those website entries so you can kind
of
find questions you might be interested
in um
all right well thanks for joining me
here
and um uh there are lots of interesting
questions saved up for next time and i
look forward to more questions next time
and um
uh i find it very interesting to give
these answers and i figure out things as
i'm um
as i'm describing them maybe i should be
telling you when i when i figured out
things i hadn't figured out before
um today there were uh four or five of
those um
but uh they're kind of not relevant to
what's being described
they're just relevant for me internally
because it's like oh i hadn't noticed
that connection before
anyway look forward to
seeing you all